looks like Christopher Nolan's really
sticking to his guns on getting this
movie release we got another trailer
here for Tennant and I'm excited to
check this one out you know Christopher
Nolan's a father okay I'm just saying
with Father's Day coming up now would be
a perfect time to take advantage of our
special discount code for the ridger
wallet we got to work on making your
segways feel more natural I've been
using my super cool Ridge wallet for
over a year now well they sent me one
even better the titanium matte black
wallet matte black like Nolan's Batman
that's it Washington David Washington
yeah cuz he's blotto John what are you
thinking sorry the wallets are super
light and durable they hold up to 12
cards and come with your choice of strap
or money clip for cash there are more
than 30 colors and designs to choose
from including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium the wallets are efficient cut
down on bulk and fits just about
anywhere and I mean anywhere and I am
now one of the thirty thousand five-star
reviews for the ridge wallet I know
that's true but still didn't sound
natural so thank you Ridge wallet for
sponsoring this video because right now
they're offering a special discount of
10% when you use our code plus free
shipping and returns worldwide all you
have to do is go to Ridge comps less
reject nation once again that's Ridge
comps us reject nation and use our promo
code reject nation are you always
interrupting me
[Music]
it's a word
it'll open the right doors to Elizabeth
de Bakey
use it carefully there's a great
Fortnight trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can communicate with the future
no inversion name it in poetry first Wow
whoa shooting you're catching it
[Music]
what I've said too much
mom we'll try and keep up
oh yeah no it's not sir yes
[Music]
[Music]
that's gonna be an amazing chase
sequence
what does it happen
[Music]
there are people in the future who need
us
they're both chill here and now
it's reversing the flow of time it
wasn't us being here now it never
happened can you can you do that with
the crow inverted get back to blow our
minds you know what the worst part about
this movie is Robert Pattinson did not
work out in this role it looks like it
shows really shows and I can't buy it
David Washington really [ __ ] up John
David Washington teaming up with another
white partner again no I don't don't fix
something the name bro probably stopped
like Landsman was just like we're doing
this he looks great in the lead role cuz
the last trailer was more like on the
heavy side and like a lot of this is on
the heavy side but what's great about
this especially with like Robert
Pattinson scarecrow who's sort of grand
I don't really know what this movie is
no-one's great with keeping the mystery
and his trailers I took that as gonna
like that he said that and in this
trailer just flat out says it's not time
very clear for everyone and Robert
Pattinson's character he kind of reminds
me a bit of a mesh of what Joseph
gordon-levitt
and Tom Hardy were in the inception
movie like the Joseph gordon-levitt role
with the Tom Hardy person yeah and this
inversion idea I'm excited for it
because you know no one's gonna provide
you to see the glimpses of it in the
trailer he's gonna provide us with some
brilliantly realized action sequences
lived in with this ridiculous crazy
sci-fi concept but this just feels like
pure Nolan in terms of like the way is
shot absolutely everything feels very
practical the way they're teasing the
plane
to be a crazy IMAX sequence isn't a you
crashed a real plane in there to do a
real plane er did you make us a really
great master that's like you know taller
the belt II did a real plane I bet they
did a real real freaking plane if
anybody would it's Christopher no yeah
kenneth branagh as the bad guy looks me
every actor in here looks incredible and
yeah the sequences just look
mind-blowing what was impressing me
about the visual effects in the
department with this weird ask it like
put the bullet coming back yeah which
kinda remember that bullet scene in the
Dark Knight that I've seen a billion
times where Bruce Wayne's firing a bunch
of bullets into the wall yeah I've seen
that scene like like I don't know how
many times now and I still no idea what
he's doing that that's what it made me
flash to hear how strong the calibers
that sequence of the bullet bounces back
what I loved is that there has to be
visual effects enhancements for all
these scenes including that that freeway
chase scene that we saw in the last
trailer with the car flipping but it all
looked real well you know this was part
of his opportunity to try some pretty
mind-blowing practical camera tricks and
stuff like it I got me thinking of the
Inception hallway fight on the freeway
with the cars you know like the crash
going backwards like I have a feeling
that whatever that device is is going to
be both you know thematically
fascinating but also really visually
dazzling too because I wonder if this
movie will use a lot of visual effects
to put reverse imagery on top of forward
moving imagery or something like that
good call that's a good call but I think
Nolan's so great at doing and it just
seems like it's present here taking
concepts ideas that can be probably
difficult to latch onto for some actors
yeah made for intelligent audience movie
goers but he also provides a film that's
not difficult to follow you know like
it's still really entertaining
throughout it's like a spy thriller with
this site by angle to it you know it's
like some weird ass looking sequences
here that I'm very much excited for
liquid that though where were that
auditorium isn't everyone's like just
knocked out no getting whatever montage
he has in here because you know there's
gonna be some great Nolan montages as
usual there's gonna be some montage here
that will really explain how all this
inversions took the inception like Reed
yeah you know I also - I wonder what
working on these movies must be like
because I almost feel like that guy on
the boat with John David Washington is
the stand-in for Christopher Nolan just
trying to get people on board for his
movies yeah like you're not gonna
understand all of it at first but we're
all gonna kind of jump into it together
and pretty soon you're gonna become
professional do ya it seems like there's
gonna be some truly dark sequences that
are there's some moments in here that
just feel that you'll get some of that a
little bit closer akin to the Nolan from
like insomnia or memento those days
where there's like a menace at times you
know yeah that really sinister black
twist at the center yeah yeah yeah
especially with this Russian bad guy you
know you gotta have that back that older
tone the insomnia tone and mix it with
inception yeah basically Elizabeth
DeBakey that's her right yeah I didn't
know she was it I think so yeah one and
Clemens Posey from Harry Potter you got
two blondes in this could be
interchangeable but yeah this looks like
it's got a really cool supporting cast
to it I always loved Nolan's flare for
like side character actors yeah you have
that guy on the boat cuz I've seen that
guy in a bunch of things too and like
you know you got your heavies like
Michael Caine and everybody but but a
lots for relying on this movie right now
the world all of cinema people are
relying yeah they'd like however that
cuz no one's sticking to his guns I'm
doing his best to make sure this still
comes out in July so depending on how it
if it does come out in July depending on
how it performs there is gonna be a huge
determining factor for a lot of movies
so lots riding on this right now I
refuse to watch this at home for the
first time I'm gonna have to watch also
I'll say that the music in here I know
it's not I don't think it's Hans Zimmer
who's scoring this but the music I
thought was great too oh yeah I mean
that's the thing I mean you know it
starts out with a blob but even just the
arpeggios and like the way it draws you
and with that mysterious it sounds
mysterious in its cereal in a way but
also you know driving like heist music
yeah exactly it's perfect it's gonna be
a fun John or blend of a film alright
guys well that's the other trailer for
Tennant did you like it if it comes out
in July will you still be going to the
theaters to check it out leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
Belva get notified whenever we got a new
YouTube video up thank you again to
Ridge wallet for sponsoring this video
make sure to hit that link in the
description box and pin come last but
not least gene Jeter killing it on
YouTube still while living on the East
Coast where it's very scary right now
he's doing his part by creating these
quarantine and chill videos but he's up
in the ante by just a little bit what
he's doing with this music to quarantine
and chill part three he's got some
beautiful women to look at in the middle
of it in case you want to look at it
while you're listening as well not just
treats for the ears but eye candy for
the eye just go to gene Jeter's channel
today listen to the quarantine and chill
part three playlist it's a great thing
to listen to when you're reading writing
whatever but also it's great to look at
oh yeah
Thank You gene for being you you stay
classy while in quarantine buddy